according to The Courier Journal a
passenger on a flight from Chicago to
Louisville was forcibly removed from an
airplane after the airline overbooked
the flight and no passenger was willing
to give up his or her seat for a stipend
from the airline three members of
security apparently began speaking with
the man who refused to leave they then
grabbed him and yank him out of his seat
and dragged him from the plane here's
what the spokesperson for United
Airlines had to say quote flight 34 11
from Chicago to Louisville was
overbooked after our team looked for
volunteers one customer refused to leave
the aircraft was voluntarily voluntarily
and law enforcement was asked to come to
the gate we apologize for the overbooked
situation further details on the removed
customer should be directed elsewhere
The Courier Journal reports the
passengers were told the plane had been
overbooked by four seats the airline
offered a $400 travel voucher and a
hotel stay which nobody took them up on
at that point the computer randomly
select four travelers on the flight and
tell them to give up their seats to
United employees were required in
Louisville for the next day one doctor
who said he needed to see patients in
the morning refused to get out of the
seat at which point security carted him
off here is the courier-journal quote
witness Audra bridges said the man
became very upset and said that he was a
doctor who needed to see patients at a
hospital in the morning the manager told
him that security would be called if he
did not leave willingly bridges said and
the man said he was calling his lawyer
the man was able to get back on the
plane after initially being taken off
his face was bloody and he seemed
disoriented bridges said and he ran to
the back of the plane passengers asked
to get off the plane as a medical crew
came on to deal with the passengers she
said and passengers were then told to go
back to the gate so that officials could
tidy up the plane before taking off
United Airlines is thinking a serious
hit publicly for this incident as well
they should it is appalling here's what
the United contract of carriage states
quote all of you as flights are subject
to over booking which could result in
you inability to provide previously
confirmed reserved space for a given
flight or for the class of service
reserved under Rule 25 of their code of
carriage United States that will
volunteer request volunteers but that if
nobody volunteers they can deny people
boarding involuntarily in accordance
with the UAE's boarding priority if
you're removed from a flight
involuntarily the airline plate pays you
a multiple of the airfare beyond your
original ticket this isn't an
unreasonable unreasonable policy
actually passengers routinely miss
flights over booking is common practice
in order to fill planes instead of
wasting money and time flying extra
routes but there are two elements here
that are unreasonable if not legal
and certainly in terms of business first
there's the question of the airline
employees bumping paying passengers yes
the airlines have contracts with their
stupid unions that require a certain
number of staffers on particular flight
when the unions Trump the customers the
business is doing a terrible job
I will admit this has happened to me
I've been forced to miss a speech before
hundreds of college students because the
airline canceled my flight then refused
to book me on the next flight in order
to fly a bunch of its own employees
second there's the problem of force why
didn't you Knight it decide which
passengers were bumped before boarding
them or better yet keep upping the offer
until somebody on the plane took it for
hundred bucks isn't a lot of money to
give to somebody to compensate them for
having to stay overnight in a location
that prevents them from working the next
day is there any question that if the
company had simply upped its bid
somebody would have taken them up on it
in the end people are going to call for
government regulation because that's
what they do but this is actually a
really good example of the market
working United is going to take a
massive public relations hit today they
lose hundreds of thousands of dollars
over this fiasco their stock price may
even be affected they'll change their
policy to ensure this never happens
again other companies will take
advantage with better service and
customers will be served and that
customer who was removed will probably
be amply compensated in settlement to
the market still works even if people
are going to want government action on
stupidities like this i'm ben shapiro
this is the venture Pierrot show
all right so we have a lot coming up
today today is the last day before
Passover Passover begins tonight so
we're going to try and jam-packed the
show even more than usual
in a little while we're going to be
having on a feminist advocate from
Connecticut named Julian Gilchrist and
she has a column in which she says that
original lists are all sexist so I have
a few questions for gilchrist so we'll
be discussing with her shortly but first
we want to say thank you to our friends
over at ring.com so if you are somebody
who worries about security I worry about
security a lot my wife and I are deeply
worried about security and have been for
years basically ever since I did the
Piers Morgan interview on CNN I've been
getting death threats pretty regularly
and so we are worried about people
coming to the house and burglarizing the
house and we're also worried about
people who ring the doorbell to see if
somebody's home and then decide whether
to enter the house or not and that's
what ring calm is good for so ring calm
what they do is they have a ring video
doorbell you put it on your fence or on
your gate or on your front door and they
ring the doorbell and then you can
actually see a camera shot of the person
who's outside the door and what's cool
is that you can do it from anywhere so
if I'm sitting right here after the show
and somebody arrives in my house and
they ring the doorbell I can pick up my
phone I can see exactly who's at the
door and I can determine whether or not
this is somebody who is safe or not this
is really great for preventing
burglaries because most burglaries are
they ring first they want to find out
whether somebody's home then they know
you're not home and then they rob the
place this helps prevent that and right
now they have an advanced motion
detection technology that you can get
with the ring of security kit which
includes the ring video doorbell for
that front door and then a ring stick up
cam which is a wireless weatherproof HD
camera to keep an eye on other parts of
your property they both install a minute
I've installed them myself and when
they're working together they do provide
that 24/7 monitoring of your entire home
whether you are there or whether you're
actually at the office or someplace else
again when I'm out of town I rely on
ring to make sure that you know
everything is okay at home and I really
enjoy and we use the product a lot
obviously for a limited time listeners
to this show can get a hundred and fifty
dollars off a ring of security kit right
now just go to ring.com slash been ring
comm slash been use that slash been see
at the hundred fifty dollars off that
ring of security kit plus they'll know
that we sent you ring.com slash been
again ring.com slash pen for that
hundred fifty bucks off the ring of
security kit okay so the
big news over the weekend we'll get to
go our search in a little while but
Gorsuch was sworn in justice justice now
Gorsuch has been sworn in to the Supreme
Court which is cool but the big story
over the weekend was not that the big
story over the weekend was obviously
what's been happening in Syria so the
big question has been what exactly is
the plan here and the Trump
administration has not made it very
clear that there is a plan so I offer
two theories last week as to what could
be going on one is Trump sauce and stuff
on TV and fired a few missiles at it
very possible because out this
personality the other is the Trump sauce
and stuff on TV saw that it was really
bad and then when his people and said
let's come up with a coherent cohesive
strategy and the first step will be
firing some cruise missiles at this
particular airbase that was responsible
for the gas attack now it is worth
noting that a couple of effects have
happened here one is that the Syrian
government immediately launched a plane
from the airbase that was supposed to be
out of order and began launching air
raids against their enemies right
afterwards to demonstrate that they had
not been hurt by the United States which
is sort of a black eye for the Trump
administration the other thing that's
happened is that Russia has become very
aggressive in its rhetoric Russia
obviously sees a central interest in
Syria one of the reasons is because
Russia has propped up the dictator Assad
there and if he falls then their
credibility in terms of guarantees for
the Iranian regime in terms of the Iraqi
regime which is now at least partially
sponsored by the Iranians that guarantee
seems to be worth a little bit less and
so the Russians want to make sure that
they stand by their man in serious
they're getting very aggressive they're
saying that they're going to treat any
bombing like this in the future as an
act of war now the real question is
going to be do we want to go up against
Russia here do we want to play a game of
chicken with them if we do play a game
of chicken are they actually going to
try and shoot down an American plane if
they did shoot down an American plane
would we then be in the state of
full-scale war with Moscow Vladimir
Putin is not in a strong position in his
own country other than the fact that he
controls the military and the money so I
mean that sounds funny because those are
the two most important things to control
but he does not control the population
the population clearly is not super fond
of Vladimir Putin and so one of the ways
he has to maintain his power is by
promoting this image of himself as a
very very powerful guy who will stand up
to anyone up to and including the United
States of America that means that he's
going to want to play chicken the United
States may have more of an interest in
allowing him
to play chicken and give off a sense of
superiority to his own people
then in challenging the Assad regime but
if Assad keeps firing gas bottoms Trump
has now set the red line the red line
exists if he if he keeps gassing people
Trump is going to have to do something
otherwise he is not just Obama he's
actually worse than Obama because he
shown that he's like Bill Clinton 1998
after the bombings in Kenya and Tanzania
they just wants to shoot a camel in the
ass and be done with it and that's not a
winning strategy when it comes to
deterrence so there are a lot of mixed
messages coming out of the
administration one message is that Assad
has to go the other message is that
Assad can sort of stay Chris Wallace
over at Fox News yes HR McMaster is the
new national security adviser a guy who
really does know military strategy his
book dereliction of duty is required
reading over at the War College and it
is a very very good book it's worth
getting he so here's Wallace asking
McMasters aren't you sending a few mixed
messages here the Trump administration
seems to be sending mixed signals this
weekend UN Ambassador nikki Haley says
that getting rid of Assad is a priority
on the other hand Secretary of State
Emerson says that first we have to get
rid of Isis destroy Isis Assad can wait
so which is it
and McMaster didn't have a great answer
for that Bernie Sanders of course says
that the Trump administration has no
plan either and when you get this guy
screaming at you you always are going to
take it with a large grain of salt but
here is Bernie Sanders talking about
Syria and why he cannot find his pudding
no matter how hard he tries asking the
Republicans what are you going to do
when you throw twenty million people off
of health insurance how many of them are
going to die what's your plan okay again
need then we'll get to we'll get to what
the actual plan is in just a second but
first I want to bring in to join us a
special guest Julianne Gilchrist who is
a feminist advocate from Connecticut she
champions public policy and issues of
gender gender-based violence and
reproductive choice she's an organizers
with women's March in Connecticut and
she currently teaches political advocacy
at the UConn School of Social Work
Julianne Gilchrist is also a she also
wrote a column for her site in which in
which she talked specifically about
the idea the judge Gorsuch would be
terrible for women in the reason that he
would be terrible for women is because
he's a proponent of originalism
professor Gilchrist are you actually a
professor or just miss Gilchrist on
addressing properly is mythical Croghan
tea miss Gail clanks well thanks for
coming on the show I appreciate it so
what you actually wrote is you wrote
that Gorsuch like Antonin Scalia is a
proponent of originalism which means he
believes the judge should attempt to
interpret the words of the Constitution
as they were understood at the time they
were written when the Constitution was
written women couldn't own property in
1787 women didn't have the right to vote
it would be 133 years before women won
that fight a fight they fought for 72
years considering women had no rights
when the Constitution was written and
there was no mention of women in the
Constitution originalism is sexist so
let me ask you first to expand on that
is it the Constitution that sexist or
originalism that sexist or both well
actually the original Constitution is
sexist and then the originalist
perspective that actually looks to the
original document is also sexist and so
we know that when a judge practices
originalism they look backwards they
don't try to see the Constitution in the
current context of society and so by
looking backwards as I said be in my
piece at the time the Constitution was
written women didn't have any rights we
were properly so yes the original s
perspective is sexist and so I think no
Corphish will not be good for women on
the Supreme Court okay so two quick
things one you're right obviously the
women did not have rights under the
Constitution in many ways the idea that
were property is an overstatement they
couldn't be sold into slavery I mean
black people were property women were
not property under the Constitution of
the United States but the but I do have
a basic question here which is what do
you think a judge's job is I mean a
judge from where I sit and according to
the structure of the Constitution his
job is to interpret the law as it's
written not to make up what he wishes
the law were that's what we have
legislatures for that's why we have
people who vote on things the idea
they're going to have some sort of super
legislature made up of the great wise
men who did or women who decide what a
text means that has nothing do with the
original meaning of the Constitution
what do you think a judge's job should
be well so what an originalist actually
does though it goes even beyond
that interpretation to an originalist
thinks that the 14th amendment which
would actually give women equal
protection based on what we know from
Justice Scalia he didn't actually think
that that protected women and so he
thinks that equal protection does not
prohibit discrimination on the basis of
sex an originalist like scalia also
feels that the right to privacy is not
included in the Constitution and so I
understand what a judge's job is but
then we also have thankfully the
legislature and so the legislature can
pass public policies that will give
women right Minaya and scalia to be fair
that that's what Scalia says I mean
that's what Robert Bork says that's what
justice Justice Thomas says but I'm an
original this is what original let's say
we say this is why we have legislators
the purpose of a legislature is to pass
things like the Civil Rights Act of 1964
you don't have judges who just sit there
and then pass legislation this is why we
have separate branches so again I ask
you you know you're upset at the outcome
of some of the of some of what the
judges say because the judges are
reading the text according to what texts
mean I mean it's not poetry but what do
you think the judge should do that is
distinct from what a legislature does
the book answer that I mean what now is
happening is to the legislature passes a
policy to give women greater access
let's use Hobby Lobby since that's the
case that Neil's sort of Gorsuch you
know ruled on the Congress passed health
care reform to allow women to have
greater access to birth control and when
that then went through the court process
because conservatives argued against
that when it went through the court
process it was ruled down and so you
know we yes we might have the
legislature yes we have judges but with
an originalist perspective like Neel
Gore stitches and like Scalia's when we
try to progress women through public
policy it's been is still being shot
down in the course because that
originals perspective as I mentioned is
a sexist perspective okay so again the
problem is that I mean take Hobby Lobby
as an example it wasn't that Neil
Gorsuch is against contraception
presumably I mean his church apparently
is Pro contraception the idea that that
Neil Gorsuch has a personal view that
anti Contras
and that's not accurate me Neil Gorsuch
is view is that there's a first
amendment to the Constitution which
protects the freedom of religion of
people like the religious owners of
Hobby Lobby and since that they don't
have to violate their own religion in
the provision of health care now you may
disagree with that policy that's why we
have an amendment process so the
Constitution does it basically enshrine
certain fundamental rights if we
disagree those fundamental rights
there's an amendment process or do you
think that we should just get rid of the
Constitution completely because it seems
to me that sort of what you want we
shouldn't have judges we shouldn't have
judicial review we shouldn't have a
constitution we should just have a
legislature that does all the things
that you want them to do or judges that
just say the legislature can do all
those things no not not at all we could
certainly we need to pass public
policies or we could amend the
Constitution and women did try that
through the Equal Rights Amendment but
that q didn't make it through right and
so to your point about Hobby Lobby it is
the first decision where two competing
interests the religious freedom
religious rights of individuals did
actually then Trump the rights of those
who need access to birth control and so
I think a different judge in that
position who doesn't have an originalist
perspective like Neil Courreges wouldn't
have rules in that way so how should it
so how should a judge read a text should
a judge just decide what the judge wants
to be the law and then just say this is
the law but what no no no you use so my
standard is that with the Constitution I
think it was supposed to be a document a
guiding document and so I don't think
anyone at the time the Constitution was
written felt that the world would always
exist as it was and so I certainly think
we need that text but we should
interpret it in light of what is
happening in present day we've changed a
lot of the culture and as a society and
so to assume that you can use a text
from hundreds of years ago to decide
cases today just be ridiculous except
that we do that with text literally
every day in the courts we use the
Sherman Antitrust Act to to rule on
antitrust we use the we use the Food and
Drug Administration Act to determine
what the FBA what the FDA is allowed to
regulate legislation is designed to be
interpreted as text you know this is
just basic legal 101 I mean you're
supposed to read a text as it's written
not as a piece of TS Eliot yes but we
use that text to interpret current
a problem and it seems that when it
comes to women's rights
originalist perspective tends to side on
the air of always looking backward
backward and not looking at current day
because they because they're trying to
because if you're looking if I wrote a
piece of legislation ten years ago and I
said to you okay were you and I write a
piece of legislation today right and we
use the language of today we mean
something by that language in this
conversation somebody will read this 100
years from now and we will have met what
we're saying to each other we understand
what we're saying if somebody wants to
read what we're talking about today and
then it turns out that all the words
that we're using now mean the reverse
because things have changed in our
conversation mean the reverse of what it
meant or does it mean what we're talking
about right now
words have meaning at the time they are
said and to try and read new meanings
into old words just because
quote-unquote times have changed you can
end up with some really bizarre results
I mean and the problem here is that you
know you may not like what Neil Gorsuch
is trying to do but at least it's a rule
of interpretation in in the
constitutional structure what we've had
is the Supreme Court very often
reversing itself on the exact same
language by using the sort of rules that
you want so for example in Plessy versus
Ferguson you have the Supreme Court say
that the Fourteenth Amendment did not
did not apply to black people insofar as
segregation was okay and then 50 years
after that they say no it turns out the
14th amendment actually meant that
segregation is not okay anymore
well that's silly I mean you neither met
one or meant the other it didn't mean
two different things at the same time
one of those decisions is wrong and one
of those decisions is right that's true
for every judicial decision the idea
that we can just look to our hearts to
determine what a text meant 200 years
ago is is silly when we can find out
what they meant 200 years ago by reading
what they're talking about now and yes I
wouldn't disagree where you made the
point though that our conversation we're
having today what we're saying to one
another is what we're saying to one
another and if looked at a hundred years
from now it would still mean the same
thing but people using our conversation
a hundred years from now would have to
apply it to that current day because
it's not going to look the same and so
we do need to look back at text but we
need to interpret them with the current
climate and so to say that I mean
Justice Scalia came out and
that the Fourteenth Amendment does not
prohibit discrimination on the basis of
sex
Justice Scalia came out and said that
there is no right to privacy in the
Constitution because there aren't any of
those things in the Constitution if you
want to establish one you create an
amendment there's no right to abortion
in the Constitution the right to privacy
is not the right to have an abortion the
right to privacy also covers the right
to access birth control and it was that
yes Griswold versus Connecticut 1965 and
well or the case but the idea that the
that the founders the people who wrote
the the Constitution were deeply
concerned with access to birth control
in the federal constitution is just
silly if you want if you this is why we
again this is why we have legislators
the point is that I'm in favor of
availability of contraception this is
why I would elect people who would be in
favor of availability of contraception
if you just want the courts to do what
you want them to do why not just appoint
a couple of oligarchs who can have Ruth
Bader Ginsburg be our queen and then we
don't actually have to have a
legislature anymore who can skip all
these expensive election things Donald
Trump wouldn't be President and and the
notorious RBG would just rule us all the
problem for women in this country is
that when we pass public policies to
increase our rights
they are then shot down by the court who
doesn't believe what you just explained
that we don't have a right to privacy or
that we don't have equal protection
under the law and so I don't want it
that's not accurate there there there
there was there dozens of states that
had already legalized abortion in large
part before roe v wade and the courts
had never struck that down on any on any
grounds I mean the you're reversing it I
mean the fact is that that if a state
legislature passes a law that makes
availability of contraception a thing
that's still not the same thing as for
example Hobby Lobby we're actually
forcing people to pay for your
contraception and violation of the
religious obligations so if you're just
talking about access to health care then
the state is perfectly capable of
passing whatever law that it wants and
the courts won't strike it down there
are countervailing their accounts are
veiling interest in some of these cases
under the Constitution and that's what
the Supreme Court is talking about in an
originalist jurisprudence but if you
want to pass a constitutional amendment
go for it again I I guess my final
question is this and unfortunately too
late an interesting conversation but my
final question is this why bother having
elections why bother having legislators
why do you if the American people are
constantly doing things
that are stupid or if the American
people are constantly electing
legislators that are terrible and if you
can just have judges who are going to be
able to apply the Constitution as you
see fit again I ask why not just appoint
Ruth Bader Ginsburg the actual queen of
the United States and she can rule from
above and she'll do all the things you
want and why isn't that okay with you I
mean tyranny with someone who you agree
with seems okay with you a little bit
tyranny is never good and right now I
feel as though we're under a tyranny I
was what is it again I'm not Trump and
I'm just wondering what he's done
exactly but we can get into that in bed
that's been another conversation for
another time
no I certainly think checks and balances
are what we need in this country you
know I'd end by saying what we haven't
tried in this country is equal
representation and so maybe when we get
a legislative body that is equally men
and women and we get a Supreme Court
that's equally men and women we might
see what about what about when we have
an electorate that's 54% women at that
point can we say that we have equal
representation because most people who
vote on it nope not yet why not what
happened to women are they are they all
slave well we might have died we might
have equal voting but we do not have
equal representation in any of our
bodies of government and so until we
have that I think we'll see a big
difference in the policies and the
rights we have as women in this country
so a woman is not really a female voter
if you elected am I'm just I'm confused
again by like like they don't know I
just think that to your point of should
we have just a judicial branch ruling
all I was answering that no we need
equal representation in all leadership
bodies in this country and so I was
speaking to that piece okay it's
fantastic we have both men and women
voting for both men and women okay so if
I'm confirm for president then she's a
woman so yeah I wouldn't go that ago I
appreciate you taking the time
Gillian Gilchrist very kind of you to
come on so I'm going to advocate from
Connecticut she is she's at the
political advocacy she teaches political
advocacy at the UConn so School of
Social Work and that people want to find
her work what's the best way to get in
touch
great they can find me on Twitter at
Jill crap that would be the best place
great really appreciate it thanks so
much yeah okay so we we have to say I
want to say thank you to to our
advertisers over at zip recruiter com
if you're looking to hire not on the
basis of sex but on the basis of merit
and and you would like to just hire
somebody who's great for the job the
best way to do that is over at zip
recruiter comm you can post your job to
200-plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and Twitter
with a single equipment click instead of
having to go all around and post it a
thousand different sites you can find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide you post once and those
tended it's just roll right on it they
have a very easy-to-use interface you
can dismiss people or accept people it's
great we're starting to use it over at
Daily wire comm and right now my
listeners can post jobs over at zip
recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire you can
post your job for free make sure you get
that slot filled again on the basis of
merit not on the basis of the gender of
the person yeah my god okay so alrighty
so I want to discuss the Syrian thing
for one more second before we have to
break on on the podcast Facebook live so
as I say before sorry final note on that
interview I just would like to note
again there is no reason that miss
Gilchrist could come up with none that
suggests that Ruth Bader Ginsburg should
not be Queen of the United States she
says she's against tyranny but then she
says that Ruth Bader Ginsburg should be
able to read whatever she wants into the
Constitution in order to apply Ruth
Bader Ginsburg values she says that
she's in favor of checks and balances
and then explicitly says that she's
angry that the Supreme Court would act
to check and balance a legislature that
oversteps its boundaries and violation
of right this just demonstrates once and
for all that when it comes to the left
view of the judiciary it is judicial
tyranny they are after they are not
after any sort of consistent rule of law
they have no idea what judges should be
doing as opposed to legislators they
think that judges should just be doing
the things they want them to do and they
have no good answers on any of this okay
when it comes to Syria as I was saying
before the interview now the fact is
there's a lot of confusion on Syria two
messages coming from the administration
one is that that that Assad should be
left in place and the other is get rid
of them so here's Rex Tillerson the
Secretary of State saying that the first
priority is to defeat Isis and for the
moment let's leave us out alone we
believe that the first priority is the
defeat of Isis that by defeating Isis
and
removing their Caliphate from their
control we have now eliminated the beast
or minimized a particular threat not
just the United States but to the hosts
ability in the region and once the Isis
threat has been reduced or eliminated I
think we can turn our attention directly
to stabilizing the situation in Syria
we're hopeful that we can prevent a
continuation of the Civil War and then
we can bring the parties to the table to
begin the process of political
discussions clearly that requires the
participation of the regime and with the
support of their allies and we're
hopeful that Russia will choose to play
a constructive role in supporting
ceasefires through their own Astana tal
I don't know Larson is entirely wrong
here when Tillerson says we have to
defeat Isis and we just have to stop
Assad from basically running roughshod
over everybody I think that's probably
the right strategy as I said last week
Alliston Assad seems to me a secondary
priority it's not like get rid of Assad
that will make the country better and
then go after Isis the question is
whether it's not even cares about going
after Isis I don't think he does I think
we're going to have to do it ourselves
that said we can keep Assad in check at
the same time we are going after Isis
the idea that we can't walk and chew gum
at the same time is silly but I do not
think that we are in a position to
rebuild the country at the same time
that we're trying to protect people from
Assad and Isis I think that's a mistake
I mean getting rid of Assad and then
having a giant chaotic vacuum when it
seems to be opening a can of worms
we have no answers to HR McMaster the
the National Security Advisor he still
seems desperate to keep Russia involved
in this he says Russia should be part of
the Russia so the solution in Syria
Medvedev wrote the u.s. is quote on the
verge of a military clash with Russia so
what are we prepared to do if Russia
defends its interests in Syria well this
is part of the problem in Syria is
Russia sponsorship for this murderous
regime and so we would want to appeal
rationally to Russia this is a great
opportunity for the Russian leadership
to reevaluate what they're doing and why
they are supporting a regime that is
committing mass murder against its own
people so it would be a great
opportunity except they're not going to
do it so what do we do next
well that's the big question so to get
that answer going to have to go over to
daily
why're calm right now and become a
subscriber you got a little too extra
today but normally you wouldn't so that
means that you have to go over to daily
wire calm you can see the rest of the
show live you can also be part of the
mailbag which we will do a little bit
later this week and right now for $8 a
month you get that subscription if you
become an annual subscriber you get a
free signed copy of reasons to vote
Democrat a comprehensive guide by our
own Michael Knowles Yale graduate it's a
it's gotten stellar review really a
stellar review from Weekly Standard comm
which is hysterical since it is an
actual blank book but it is a great gag
gift it is the most thorough book on
democratic ideology there is go check it
out over at Daley wire.com becoming the
annual subscriber or if you just want to
listen later then go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud leave us a review we
appreciate it
it helps iTunes recognize that we are a
massive podcast because indeed we are
our numbers are seller you are listening
to the grandest and most glorious
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you